what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we are back i'm back from my little
vacation out to cincinnati and lexi to
kentucky to see my sister for her
birthday which was really really cool so
let's record some audio and cover some
stories so we're picking back up again
with spider-man honestly i want to kind
of get to the end of worldwide and then
we might go into nick spencer's run
honestly i love nick spencer's
spider-man run it's one of my secret
favorite comics that i read that i just
don't really cover here on the channel
which as a comic book youtuber you need
those right you need the stories that
you just don't cover you just read them
for the sake of your own personal
enjoyment otherwise it feels like it
stops it stops being enjoyable having
said that there's a couple things to
know here um i had i've been hunting
through my youtube channel because i was
so sure that we covered the fall of
parker's storyline which is part of
marvel legacy and it turned out that we
did right so the big thing to really
come out of the fall of parker was
basically the collapse of parker
industries right that the last video
that we did peter parker was the ceo of
just like this massive parker industries
corporation which had initially been
launched by superior spider-man when
doctor octopus was in the body of peter
parker and that going into all-new all
different marvel peter had gotten his
body back and was now the ceo this all
basically concluded in the secret empire
event which we might add to the
spider-man playlist just to kind of make
it make sense as far as transitioning
goes otherwise you just kind of jump and
like there's all these huge changes the
idea behind this was that because
captain america's history had been
changed by the red skull using a cosmic
cube to make captain america into a
hydra agent that the biggest concern or
one of the big concerns is that given
everything he done as a kind of focal
point of the superhero community knowing
everybody's weaknesses and so on is that
by blocking superheroes from getting to
earth right the heavy hitters like carol
danvers or hyperion or anybody like that
keeping them out of the fray and then
basically conquering north america if he
got his hands on parker industries tech
that it would have allowed him to expand
his reach in a way that just simply
wasn't possible at the time and then
ultimately conquer the world most likely
and so in order to prevent that from
happening peter parker quite literally
torched his own company he basically
ended up tanking parker industries
destroyed all his technology and
everything to make sure captain america
couldn't get his hands on it the good
side of this is that it saved countless
people from the crazy mechanations of
captain america the downside is that it
killed parker industries as a company
and peter parker screwed over a lot of
folks right a lot of people got left
hanging people's entire pensions were
tied up in parker industries people had
investments people worked for the
company so millions and millions of
people in one form or another across the
world basically lost everything as a
result of peter destroying his own
company and so that's why at this point
in the spider-man mythos under dance
slots run it's an opposite of what it
used to be that spider-man was always
kind of considered the menace by like
you know the daily bugle and that peter
parker was like the kid who was just
kind of there and doing some cool stuff
and people more or less liked him it was
the opposite that peter parker was
considered the menace and spider-man was
hailed as the hero right so it it
offered a kind of cool psychological uh
take on the the nature of spider-man in
the sense that peter had to contend with
the idea that people hated him as a
person but they loved spider-man but one
of the big things that goes on here is
that you actually end up having this
this kind of scenario where you're
introduced to something that's basically
called the lock box now the lock box is
kind of a submersible it's almost like
the raft in marvel comics those of you
guys who don't know the raft is a prison
for super powered villains right the
lock box is a kind of prison or a
holding place for super powerful
artifacts right so things like the
casket of ancient winners and so on and
so forth the big kicker behind all this
is that those individuals who grab who
basically kind of sent out to grab these
artifacts that are basically taken to
the lock box are not necessarily told
what they are and a lot of this is done
for the purpose of making sure that like
their desires don't really get the
better of them because it's kind of a 50
50 guess right in all honesty it's one
half dependent on the loyalty of the
people who work there that they don't
ask questions and they do that because
they're told to and the other half fear
they're afraid that what they might do
is open the box and unleash a deadly
plague across the whole world and kill
everybody and so because of this what
you actually end up having is a couple
people named crane and coleman and what
ends up going on is that as craig and
coleman are bringing this artifact into
the lock box suddenly like they start
getting these kind of fluctuations from
a device that's held in a containment
cell that's known as containment cell
12. now this turns out to be the zodiac
key this is not an overly important
thing and that's one of the things we're
going to kind of do here is there's not
a lot of stuff that's super important
here it's more of like what happens at
the back of the stories and and you'll
see why that's so important as we get to
it but the zodiac key was basically a
device that has existed for a long time
in marvel comics it originally hailed
from a place called the unk dimension
which was basically a dimension where
the key itself kind of existed to
maintain uh the conflict between good
and evil it eventually arrived on earth
and it's been used by various people but
it kind of has a mind of its own right
so if you're a person who picks up the
zodiac key and you're like i want to end
all conflict between good and evil and i
want the world to be a utopia the key
will leave you right and it'll go to
somebody else because the desire of the
key is to instigate conflict it's
basically social media in a physical
form and so because of that
the key itself was a was at one point uh
really possessed by a guy named vernon
fury who of course is basically
descended from the original nick fury he
was a guy that operated under the mantle
of scorpio we covered that in the early
spider-man runs from all new all
different marvel by by dan slott the
important thing is he was basically
pushed into a vault by peter parker uh
which was essentially the zodiac vault
he gained a year's worth of knowledge
about all the things that are gonna
happen within a year in the future and
then basically is being freed from the
vault at the moment right so it's not an
important thing like a great big huge
fight ensues between peter and vernon
and then basically the you know vernon's
arrested right i mean there's not a
whole lot to go there i mean the meat
and potatoes of this right like the the
real important thing about this is that
verdun is really intending to use like
the satellite systems of the world to
essentially dump the world's secrets out
there for everybody to see because what
it'll do is that'll create conflict
right people realizing like their best
friend's been sleeping with their wife
right or like people realizing their
boss is like cheating them out of pay or
something along those lines whatever the
case happens to be right but like all
the secrets that everybody has around
the world which are largely kept in the
digital space are gonna be dumped out
there for the world to see the important
thing about all this the most important
thing here is coleman and crane because
while they're all kind of there while
they're inside the inside the the lock
box they're actually on a mission of
their own traveling from one location to
the next trying to access a particular
cell and the big thing is that as they
come across different soldiers of the
lockbox they basically kill them right
they spray them down and it's just like
you know we're here for a mission of our
own and that's kind of the crazy thing
is because when they're when they're
confronted by the leader of the lock box
it's like why are you doing this like
your your whole background was checked
multiple times and their response is but
here's the thing we work for a guy who
pays more than you do so sure we have a
clean background you just didn't pay
enough money right that's the thing
about hired guns right like their
loyalty is to whoever pays the most
that's the the dangerous game you play
so if you're government workers anybody
says the government pays cheap
and so when you buy cheap you get cheap
and that's basically how things went
down here now as for for vernon himself
of course spider-man traces him down or
locates him at big ben which was a place
where previously his organization had
basically created a kind of resonance
device that the key could tap into and
then use that to access the satellites
right so it's like if the satellites
speak french and the zodiac speaks
spanish the this whole big ben key
system is a translator is basically what
it is and so peter parker is really
unable to get it out but then comes to
this realization that previously the key
responded to vernon because he needed it
right that the key and vernon are kind
of in tune with each other because
vernon basically stands the best
possible chance of allowing the key to
achieve its goal which is basically
creating conflict and all kinds of
massive issues right this massive battle
between good and evil on a physical and
even a philosophical level and so the
key response to him and so what peter
parker does is pretty shady here peter
parker knocks this guy out of big ben
[Laughter]
literally sends this guy like flying
through the glass on the front plate and
vernon's just falling to his death the
key leaves his position and responds to
vernon which of course prevents the key
from being able to access the satellite
systems dumping their information into
the world and then in turn of course
vernon's basically snatched up by uh by
a combination of mockingbird and the
cops right you know he's knocked
unconscious and he's taken to jail and
that's the end of that right that's what
a lot of this stuff is and so what you
end up finding out here is the mission
that coleman and crane were sent on was
paid for by norman osborne and what he
was trying to do and what he's been
trying to do is find a way to become the
green goblin again ever since he was
given the cure to the goblin formula
during superior spider-man and lost his
ability to become the green goblin it's
like a drug addiction right he's always
trying to find a way back always trying
to get this this goblin back because
it's just part and parcel to who he is
and so ultimately you end up finding out
the artifact that coleman and crane had
attained was a portion of the carnage
symbiote that what norman osborne's
trying to do is regain his ability to
become the green goblin by merging with
carnage now a lot of the reason for this
is because in the eyes of norman osborn
carnage represents just chaos in the
most visceral way right just chaos and
pandemonium and in a lot of ways carnage
and the green goblin were very similar
in terms of their personalities right
that they were basically insane they
love to inflict harm so on and so forth
the big difference between carnage and
green goblin is green goblin's insanity
and his his motivations to you know
commit all kinds of heinous crimes were
usually targeted towards spider-man with
carnage it's everybody right it's just
like if if he could drive the world into
total insanity and kill everybody there
then he would right there's there's no
real uh instance where carnage hates
spider-man in particular he more often
than not was a spider-man villain but
that's because he gained his original
prominence fighting spider-man and venom
the reason why carnage is so so
prominent now is because he's not just a
spider-man villain anymore that he's one
of these guys where he could pop up and
face off against virtually anybody and
any number of things could happen it's
one of the things that makes them so
cool but again there's a few other
things to go on here the important thing
is that with norman osborne in
possession of the carnage symbiote this
is one of those instances where it's the
monkey's paw right be careful what you
wish for you just might get it and
that's exactly what happens here norman
osborne does not understand the very
nature of what the carnage symbiote
represents and a lot of that's because
he has he hasn't had any real dealings
with it before if this was peter parker
who was here and norman osborne was
getting ready to bond to the carnot
symbiote peter parker would say do not
do that you don't know what like you
have no idea what you're getting into
bonding to the carnage symbiote but at
the end of the day norman osborne sees
the symbiote as something that can be
dominated something that can be
controlled and the reason why is his
only real understanding about the
symbiotes comes from venom but venom and
carnage are distinctly different that
the venom symbiote is a symbiote that
bonds itself to eddie brock and they
kind of work in unison because initially
they both had a hatred for peter parker
a lot of that's changed over the years
in terms of the role that venom has
played with regards to how it views
itself how it views peter the fact that
in like the current day and age eddie
brock is actually a good guy but the
carnage symbiote is a whole different
beast that the carnage symbiote has a
will of its own in a far more intense
way than venom does and that's why as
soon as the symbiote starts to bond
itself to norman osborne norman
osborne's like no no no no he doesn't
want to have anything to do with he's
like i want an empire right i want to
rule things and connor's like no we're
going to kill everybody right like
literally the will of carnage dominates
the the will of norman osborne to the
point that norman osborne is almost a
passenger seat in his own life with the
carnage symbiote in possession of him
and that's what makes things so crazy is
because the power of of carnage in
comparison to what norman osborne is
used to it's on a whole different level
right that the green goblin did kind of
have its own personality to a degree
there was actually a point where the
green goblin and norman osborne were two
distinctly different people but even the
personal drives and motivations of the
green goblin as its own entity were
nothing on par with regards to what
carnage has insofar as having a will of
its own and being able to dominate the
will of others but that's one of the
things that makes norman osborne so
unique is because even in the most
insane situations in this part like this
where he would normally be completely
and totally overcome by the will of
carnage norman osborne is nothing if not
a master manipulator and depending on
who you're talking to you could even
consider him a demagogue but the
important thing here is that where
carnage just ends up killing coleman and
crane the response of norman osborne is
i can give you more of this i can give
you more of this desire of this this
satisfaction that comes with just
destroying people right killing them so
on and so forth and so khan is like yes
give me more i want more of this right i
miss this feeling of of taking lives and
so on and that's when norman says okay
fine i will give you that but only on
one condition i am in the driver's seat
i'm the one who's in control show me you
understand and the carnage symbiote
responds by saying like i understand and
woman's like okay cool and that's what
kind of brings norman back in control
because the response of this is like you
know what let's try something else right
let's try something that we haven't done
before let's try something interesting
he says we can be greater than this yes
i have this carnage symbiote which is
more than enough to take out peter
parker but what if we switch things up
right i can become the goblin again i
can become something more we can become
something more and so what he ends up
doing is basically breaking out the
goblin formula that he kept on him right
remember he got that formula back he has
a goblin formula on him and then in turn
consumes it and so what you're going to
end up having here is the green goblin
and carnage merging into a singular
being and things get
crazy with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace